[Music]
what do you think it is about bird by
bird
that affected so many people so deeply
and certainly that's true of many of
your other
works but in this particular case what
do you think it is that
has that type of effect on people
i think it's because
i didn't try to con people into thinking
that if they just got a book finished
that my agent will want to take a look
at it by the end of the week and that it
would almost certainly be published and
that then they would
all the swiss cheese holes inside of
them would be healed and they'd be well
and they'd get that fda stamp of
approval and be validated and then their
parents would start to respect them i
said none of that's going to happen all
of that is an inside job but
i'll tell you a funny story when sam's
little boy who's 12 now was five i was
teaching his kindergarten class a
writing workshop and instead of saying
shitty first drafts i said really poopy
first drafts but after and the kids
loved me and after i was done my little
grandchild came up to me and he leaned
in and he sounded like tony sopriano he
said oh nana that was terrible and i
said what and he said you told people
you would teach them how to write a book
but you only taught us how to write one
page
and that's really what i can help you do
is one chapter is on shitty first drafts
i don't try to teach kids or grown-ups
how to write really really well i just
teach them to stop not writing i teach
them to keep their butt in the chair and
to write badly and that all first drafts
of any book you've ever read by the
authors you esteem most began as
unreadable first drafts and i teach
people to take it really small you know
bird by bird is it okay if i tell the
story please please i i would love for
you to tell the story just that people
know the genesis
well my older brother i was like a
superstar achiever in school my older
brother hated school and he was kind of
a rebel and in california in the 50s and
early 60s
in fourth grade you wrote two term
papers one was the sacramento paper
that's our state capital and the other
was on birds and you had to write it all
year all semester a paper on birds and
my brother hadn't started it was due on
a monday and on a saturday he admitted
to my dad that he hadn't started
my brother was a tough guy and he was in
tears and my dad sat down with him and
put his arm around him and he said just
take it bird by bird buddy you know
first you read about chickadees
and then you write a paragraph in your
own words about chickadees and then you
draw a picture and then you take
pelicans and you study up on pelicans
and then you write a paragraph or a
passage on pelicans i never ever forgot
that and then years later probably 20
years ago so
in my 40s i heard el doctoro say
that riding was like driving at night
with the headlights on you could only
see a little ways in front of you
but you could make the whole journey
that way and i think that is the most
profound advice i can offer anyone on
any topic that you you you can only see
a little ways in front of you and and
you can make the whole journey that way
and another another thing that i think
helped people when they read bird by
bird was
the chapter on perfectionism and how
perfectionism is the voice of the
oppressor it's the voice of the enemy
and if you listen to it keeps you crazy
for your entire life because
because we all fall short you know
you've written books and you think
you're creating this golden and crystal
palace that people can walk inside of
and see all of truth and beauty and
reality and you kind of end up your
books and my books all all of them are
kind of shanty towns you know and like
indeed
during the peace marches where people
set up tents and thought it made sense
to bring their dogs you know during the
rainstorm and that's a miracle to
written a shanty town and so i think
these ideas of not knowing what you're
doing
and of letting yourself do it really
badly
and to try to help
grind down that critical voice i'll just
mention my husband's
work here he he's uh neil allen he wrote
shapes of truth and the work he does
with people and these shapes of truth is
taming the inner critic and what his
position is you're never going to get
rid of it you know we don't get over
very much here what he does with people
is he has him bring forth the inner
critic and actually just put it on the
table in front of him and he he thanks
them for keeping them him alive when he
was six and seven because it kept him
small and controllable so he didn't run
out into the street he didn't swim out
past his ability to stay afloat but that
at the age of 60 or whatever we probably
don't need it anymore and so he has his
clients give the inner critic a great
new job which might be ethical
consultant for the project so that the
inner critic can go off to the library
where there's an incredibly comfortable
chair and a good reading light and two
thousand books and he will sit there and
read what he loves to do and when we
need an ethical consultation we'll come
get him but we don't need that constant
is it allow okay to say the f word on oh
yes
please oh in bird by bird there's a
whole chapter on k [ __ ] radio kfkd and
without a lot of help and a lot of
transformation and healing
k [ __ ] radio's on 24 7. it's telling
you how far short you're falling it's
telling you how great you started out
and what a disappointment you've turned
out to be it's telling you that what
you're in the middle of is beating a
dead on and on and on and so the shapes
of truth work and the
inner critic work and bird by bird is
90 percent about turning down k [ __ ]
radio anyway out of the left-hand
speaker is all this stuff about that you
you can't do it perfectly and that why
bother and that this has been blah blah
blah but out of the right-hand speakers
it's like the voice of the people who
love you most the voice of like for me
sam or my husband or my two best
girlfriends and they're saying i love
your stories i love how you write i
can't wait to read more so but you can
turn down the left-hand speaker and
it'll always be there to some degree
you